that trailer was amazing okay i had to
look it up just to make sure i was right
because i didn't want to make a video
where i say galactus is in the marvel
cinematic universe
and it's not galactus it's that ultron
vision hybrid where you can see infinity
stones
yeah cool whatever you know what i'm
really excited about when it comes to
the mcu to like the whole what if series
i'm excited about the idea of schuma
goraz that's what i'm excited about
right
a demonic entity that not even dr
strange can defeat i know a lot of
people are like you're just gonna gloss
over ultron
merge with vision with the infinity
stones yes i am
i am definitely going to gloss over that
is it cool sure but like we've already
seen ultron and we already know what
vision looks like so we know what their
personalities are like
i don't know i feel like it'd be like
his personality would be like if the
watcher got the infinity stones it
wouldn't be the most interesting thing
ever you understand what i mean
like maybe it'll be cool in the show
regardless i guess the infinity stones
are always cool but schumer gorath is
what i care about all right schumacher
is a cool thing those of you guys who
don't know and i'm i'm assuming this is
the case i don't know who else it would
be
but in that scene in the what if trailer
we've seen it a couple times now
where you have that giant tentacle
monster like spider-man swings into it
that looks like schumacher but here's
the funny thing about it if they're
gonna do anything like they do in the in
marvel comics
that's not really schuma gorath that's
like an avatar of
gorath here's something to understand
about beings like this guy
and i'll make sense of him here in a
minute but here's the thing to
understand about guys like that
shumogorath doesn't really appear in his
like real
native form if he did he would kill
everybody like everybody would die right
and i mean when i say everybody i mean
everybody like thor the hulk doctor
strange captain america and iron man
definitely like
all those guys would just die right so
here's the thing about schuma gorath
right and this is why this guy is a game
changer
we already know that he's going to
appear or at least supposed to appear in
doctor strange too
but if you thought thanos was a
legitimate threat he's got nothing on
this dude right so
schumachorath is what we call a great
old one or a mini angled one or they
have different names right he's
basically an eldritch demon
there was a point in the history of
marvel comics when he ruled earth when
he like conquered the whole thing
he was ultimately defeated in the old
conan books which was kind of weird
people have used the dark hole to try to
bring him back we already know the dark
hole exists in the mcu from one division
so he's one of these guys where if he
ever were to return
in full power he'd be unstoppable now
what does it mean that he's a mini
angled one and more specifically
what's this guy's origin well the funny
thing about the mini angled ones the
great old ones whatever you want to call
them
they don't really have an origin that we
know of we simply just know that they
were here at some previous point in time
by whatever manner and whatever means
they were effectively defeated
now we don't know how all of them were
defeated we simply just know that they
were
a lot of this seems to go back to
agamotto the very first sorcerer supreme
the very first person to ever find a way
to basically channel magical energy and
then use it for his own ends
but we don't specifically know if that's
the case there's really no source that
cites their origin here but what we do
know
is that the many angled ones basically
exist in between
universes and they're always trying to
find a way out right they're always
trying to find a way to leave this place
between universes
and enter into entire universes as far
as we know schuma gorath was the only
one to do it and to successfully conquer
other realities because that's the thing
to know this guy conquered
multiple universes right there's whole
universes that all just been their will
to schuma gorath now a lot of it's
because of the power he possesses
the ability to like shape-shift the
ability to dominate the minds of others
right
forcing entire like universes into
subservience and to give you guys a
perspective on what that means
that means in each one of these
universes shumogorath went in
and destroyed or conquered that
universe's version of galactus
eternity anybody who could have used the
infinity stones against him
anybody who could have used a cosmic
cube like the cosmic entities like
conquering the whole universe is not
just beating the avengers and calling it
a day
it's conquering a whole host of people
everyone ranging from people like iron
man with a giant metal
suit and captain america with the super
soldier serum all the way up to people
who are quite literally the walking
talking embodiment of the universe
and even those individuals who can
manipulate the fundamental structure
of the universe who could basically do
what thanos did with the reality stone
without having to use a reality stone
it's just their natural power
but beyond schuma gorham the only time
that we're aware of that any of the
great old ones were able to like
infiltrate the universe
came during the thanos imperative
storyline of marvel comics and here's
the thing behind this the thanos
imperative storyline was basically a
story that came out of a handful of
different things one of which was called
something called the war of kings it
doesn't really matter we talked about
that in a previous video
the important thing here is you have
what was called a fault which was
basically a rip
in space time now what you had was a
future version of adam warlock named the
magus who led a group called the
universal church of truth
these guys conquered whole worlds right
entire worlds were conquered by these
guys
they teleported all these worlds and all
their ships to the fault blew it wide
open and then like the cancer verse came
out which was basically an alternate
reality
where mistress death was killed and
nobody could die the reason why this
matters is because the many angled ones
got their way
into that universe through doctor
strange and then once they were let in
they conquered everything
and so they turned all the avengers into
just twisted evil versions of themselves
called the revengers now i've been
saying for a long long time
that the what if series is going to have
a common plot thread
that runs through the entire thing that
this whole series is not going to exist
in isolation i don't think it will it
doesn't make any sense that it would
because in the marvel cinematic universe
nothing has existed in isolation up to
this point
virtually everything has in some form or
fashion
tied into everything else whether it be
a post-credit scene or something like
captain america
shield appearing in iron man and iron
man 2. regardless of the situation
everything ties into everything else and
it seems kind of strange that they would
go through all this work and make that a
cornerstone of the mcu
just to deviate when it comes to the
what if animated series and so i think
there's going to be a big plot thread
here and i think that schumagorath type
being is going to be that plot thread
that we know
from doctor strange 2 the leaks and
things like that that schumachorath is
chasing after america chavez those of
you guys who don't know what that is
america chavez is not wildly interesting
she's never really had any good books
but what she can do is jump between
dimensions she can create portals to
other universes
and then enter into those universes if
somebody like shumogorath is trying to
escape the space between universes
or assuming that he exists in some
universe that's returned with the
multiverse
where it's literally just a universe of
demonic beings and he's just trying to
get out of it
that somebody like america chavez would
catch his attention because she's the
best person to use
to essentially possess and then travel
throughout the entirety of the
multiverse
however it is that he sees fit and it
could be one of these things where he
maybe somehow managed to escape or
he made his way into this universe by
whatever the case happens to be
and now we see the events unfolding in
the what if episode right i'm
ballparking
here we have no idea what it's going to
look like we got like two weeks until we
find out
which i'm excited about but regardless
we don't really know exactly how that's
going to unfold
but we know that just by virtue of the
history of the mcu
things tie in that's one of the things
that i'm kind of hoping for not to sound
too masochistic here
but i'm hoping that some of these
episodes don't end on a positive note
because one thing to know about the what
if series in marvel comics
they don't end on a positive note more
often than not they end badly
they end very very badly right it's just
kind of like yeah man
and this is how things could have
unfolded and everything sucks right like
the original secret wars event from 1984
where spider-man first game the venom
symbiote there's a what-if story for
that
and what you end up finding out is a
venom symbiote actually consumed the
the entire biological structure of peter
parker except for his bones and so
there's one point where the symbiote's
blown off what they thought was peter
parker
and it's just his bones he's just
walking around in his bones it's the
weirdest thing
right like there's a what-if story where
like the punisher's family doesn't get
killed in central park
instead they get killed later and he
ends up becoming the punisher anyway
right like
these things usually end pretty badly
there's a story where doctor strange
becomes a disciple of dormammu
one where jean grey gets the phoenix
force and obliterates all of creation
there's
all kinds of these these really cool
white of stories but they usually all
end pretty badly
and that's something that i would kind
of keep in mind here going into this is
you're not really going to see a lot of
these episodes that have a happily ever
after kind of
ending where it's like and then iron man
and captain america showed up
and the day was saved like it's probably
not going to happen like the the one
that features ultron and vision that are
merged together with the infinity stones
he's probably going to kill the marvel
universe right he's probably going to
kill everything in existence in that
episode right wipe it all out and just
call it a day
or it'll end up being like the ultron
forever story arc where basically all
the avengers got turned into ultron
robots
if you guys don't know about that story
it's amazing i'm pretty sure we covered
the comments explained and if we do
you'll find a link down in the
description if we didn't we'll cover it
when that episode comes out
because it's a really really really cool
story but this is the kind of thing that
you get with the what if series but i'm
really hoping
that's schumachura i'm really hoping
it's that demonic entity that if it ever
returned to full power
people couldn't stop it and that's
something to know when it comes to
beings like that in mobile comics as
powerful as doctor strange is
beings like dormammu zom shumagorath if
they ever
showed up with the full totality of
their power they'd be unstoppable
no one could defeat them not even the
the cosmic entities could beat them
somebody like the living tribunal
definitely could but beyond that like
nobody could really defeat those guys
right they're just on that level of
power it's that extreme
so i think it'd be cool to see that kind
of stuff i don't know if marvel's using
thanos with the infinity gauntlet is
like the ceiling
and saying like no characters that we're
going to see in the marvel cinematic
universe
are ever going to be as powerful as him
but i hope that's not the case i hope
that we actually end up seeing
characters in the mcu
that are way beyond the power of thanos
with the infinity gauntlet because
here's a little secret for those of you
guys who don't know
thanos with the infinity gauntlet that's
small time that's
chump change there are guys out there
who would crush thanos with the infinity
gauntlet
and not even buy a little bit right like
that fight would be two seconds long
it would it wouldn't even be any bit of
a conflict at all right like
the molecule man the marquee of death
matthew malloy
gambit from the x-men when he was new
son like there's all kinds of characters
out there who would just crush thanos
with the infinity wall and it wouldn't
even be fair
but let me know what you guys think down
in the comments section about the
trailer i know it's a little 30 second
tv
spot not a whole lot to go on here but
let me know how excited you guys are
about the what if series because i am
looking
forward to it but with that being said
guys we're going to bring this to an end
thank you guys for watching
and i will catch you all later peace